IF YOU BELIEVE IN BORDERS
YOU ARE A MONSTER.
THIS ISN'T YOUR COUNTRY, IT
BELONGS TO OTHER PEOPLE NOW.
THAT'S THE MESSAGE THEY'RE
SENDING EXPLICITLY.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF
SESSIONS JOINS US RIGHT NOW.
MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL, THANKS
FOR COMING ON.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: THIS IS, I THINK
IT'S FAIR TO SAY, AN
GOVERNMENT IS MAKING IT
POSSIBLE FOR AN ACCUSED
KILLER TO GO FREE SIMPLY
BECAUSE THEY ARE MORALLY
OPPOSED TO FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION LAW.
THAT'S SETTING UP A CONFLICT
BETWEEN THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
HOW CAN THIS BE STOPPED?
WHAT'S THE NEXT STEP HERE?
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE
GOT TO SPEAK FIRST AND
FOREMOST TO THESE
GOVERNMENTAL LEADERS.
JUST UNACCEPTABLE TO TAKE
THIS CASE IN DENVER THAT YOU
JUST CITED WHERE THE
INDIVIDUAL WILL BE RELEASED
FROM JAIL.
OUR ICE OFFICERS ARE NOT
GOING TO STOP LOOKING FOR
HIM.
THEY ARE GOING TO GO OUT TO
FIND HIM.
THEY WILL BE AT GREATER
RISK.
THEY WILL PLACE PEOPLE IN
THE COMMUNITY AT GREATER
RISK TO TRY TO MAKE AN
ARREST THERE WHEN THEY COULD
HAVE BEEN SAFELY PICKED UP
IN THE CUSTODY FROM THE
CUSTODY OF THE DENVER
AUTHORITIES.
SO, THIS SITUATION IS VERY,
VERY SERIOUS AND IT
REPRESENTS A COMMITMENT FROM
THE HARD LEFT, THESE
ACTIVIST GROUPS TO OPEN
BORDERS AND NON-LEGAL
ENFORCEMENT OF IMMIGRATION.
CANNOT BE THE POLICY OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
>> Tucker: SO, SOME
DEMOCRATIC POLITICIAN SAY
THE STATES ARE NOT AND I
THINK THEY ARE LEGALLY
CORRECT, ARE NOT OBLIGATED
TO CARRY OUT FEDERAL LAW.
BUFF THEN OTHERS, INCLUDING
THE MAYOR OF OAKLAND, HAVE
GONE FARTHER AND ACTIVELY
TRIED TO SUBVERT FEDERAL LAW
AS MAYOR LIBBY SCHAAF OF
OAKLAND DID THE OTHER DAY BY
WARNING PEOPLE THAT FEDERAL
AGENTS ARE COME.
DOES THAT CONSTITUTE
CONSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE AND
SHOULD SHE BE PROSECUTED FOR
THAT?
>> WE ARE LOOKING AT THAT
OUR FABULOUS ICE OFFICES AND
TOM HOMAN ARE KEEPING US
POSTED ON WHAT IS HAPPENING
THERE.
THOSE KIND OF THINGS DEPEND
ON THE LAW AND THE FACTS AND
WE WILL EVALUATE THEM AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
YES, THIS IS A RADICAL
ETIOLOGY.
IT'S CONTRARY TO THE
AMERICAN LAW.
THE SUPREME LAW OF THE LAND
IS AMERICAN IMMIGRATION LAW.
AND IT MUST BE ENFORCED ELSE
WE WILL JUST HAVE OPEN
BORDERS AND THAT CANNOT BE.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE OPEN
BORDERS IN EFFECT A LOT OF
WAYS.
NOW WE ARE GETTING SOMETHING
THAT LOOKS LIKE INSURRECTION
ALMOST.
THE BIGGEST STATE SAYING
WE'RE GOING TO ACT TO
UNDERMINE BASIC FEDERAL LAW.
DO YOU WORRY THAT THE
COUNTRY WON'T HANG TOGETHER?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
I THINK THIS IS AN EXTREME
ACT.
WHEN I WAS IN CALIFORNIA, I
HEARD COUNTLESS PEOPLE TELL
ME THEY WERE EMBARRASSED AND
OUTRAGED ABOUT WHAT WAS
GOING ON.
I THINK THESE PEOPLE HAVE
JUST BEEN ABLE TO GET AWAY
WITH IT NOT BEEN CHALLENGED.
NOT BEEN CHALLENGED
INTELLECTUALLY AS TO THE
MEANING OF WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.
HOW RADICAL IT IS.
HOW UNACCEPTABLE IT IS.
HOW IT PLACES THE LIVES OF
AMERICAN POLICE OFFICERS AND
ICE OFFICERS AT GREATER RISK
AS WELL AS OUR COMMUNITIES
AT GREATER RISK BECAUSE WE
KEEP CRIMINALS IN THE
COUNTRY THAT ARE DUE TO BE
DEPORTED.
>> Tucker: DO YOU SEE HOW IF
YOU ARE LOOKING ON AS AN
OBSERVER OF THIS IT DOES
FEEL LIKE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS TOOTHLESS IN
THE FACE OF THIS CHALLENGE.
ELECTED OFFICIALS STAND UP
GIVE THE FINGER TO
AUTHORITIES, TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT WITH IMPUNITY.
IT DOES SEEM LIKE THEY, THE
MAYOR OF OAKLAND HAS MORE
POWER THAN THE FEDS.
>> WELL, TUCKER, WE ARE
GOING TO USE EVERY LAWFUL
TOOL WE HAVE TO PUSH BACK
AGAINST THIS ACTIVITY.
YOU CAN BE SURE OF THAT.
I WILL SAY, HOWEVER, THAT
ULTIMATELY, IN THIS COUNTRY,
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE THE
FINAL WORD.
AND THEY HAVE GOT TO ANALYZE
WHAT THEIR LEADERS ARE
DOING, AND IF THEY ARE
PROMOTING THESE KIND OF
UNLAWFUL, UNWISE AND
DANGEROUS POLICIES, THEY
NEED TO BE HELD TO ACCOUNT.
AND WHEN THE POLITICAL
NEEDLE STARTS MOVING, I
THINK YOU WILL SEE
POLITICIANS START CHANGING.
>> Tucker: THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL YOU REPLACED.
ONE ATTORNEY GENERAL BEFORE
THAT ERIC HOLDER, HAS
ENDORSED THIS.
DO YOU THINK IT'S ODD THAT A
FORMER CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER IN THE COUNTRY WOULD
BE ENDORSING IGNORING
FEDERAL LAW?
>> WELL, IS HE BEING HIRED
BY THE STATE.
BEING PAID A LEGAL FEE TO
REPRESENT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BUT, I TOTALLY BELIEVE THAT
THIS POLICY THAT THEY ARE
DEFENDING IN CALIFORNIA IS
UNWISE AND MANY PLACES
CLEARLY ILLEGAL.
WE ARE GOING TO CHALLENGE
ITS LEGALITY AND WOULD ARE
GOING TO CHALLENGE ITS
WISDOM.
AND WE ARE GOING TO DEFEND
FEDERAL LAW OFFICERS AND
STATE LAW OFFICERS WHO ARE
OUT THERE TRYING TO DO THEIR
DUTY EVERY DAY AND BEING
PLACED AT MUCH GREATER RISK
BECAUSE THEY WON'T EVEN LET
THE POLICE TALK TO THE
FEDERAL OFFICERS WHO ARE THE
ONLY ONES THAT CAN ACTUALLY
DEPORT A CRIMINAL ALIEN.
>> Tucker: JUST TO SWITCH
GEARS, I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE, CERTAINLY I THINK A
LOT OF OUR VIEWERS HAVE LOST
CONFIDENCE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND
INTELLIGENCE-GATHERING
AGENCIES IN THIS COUNTRY
BECAUSE THEY THINK THEY HAVE
BEEN USED FOR POLITICAL
PURPOSES TO SPY ON AMERICANS
WITHOUT REAL CAUSE.
AND CARTER PAGE, I THINK,
WOULD BE AT THE TOP OF THAT
LIST.
DON'T YOU THINK IT WOULD GO
A LONG WAY TO RESTORING
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN THOSE
AGENCIES IF THE REST OF US
HAD SOME SENSE THAT THE
BASIS UPON WHICH THE FISA
WARRANTS WERE GOTTEN FOR
SPYING ON CARTER PAGE?
>> IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY
AND I THINK MY
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE
THAT THE FISA PROCESS IS
CARRIED OUT PROFESSIONALLY,
PROPERLY, LAWFULLY, AND WITH
INTEGRITY.
I INTEND TO DO THAT.  WE ARE
WORKING ON THAT NOW.
OUR OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL HAS ALMOST 500
EMPLOYEES, INVESTIGATORS,
AND PROSECUTORS.
AND THEY ARE GOING TO WORK
ON THIS AND GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT.
>> Tucker: THERE IS SO MUCH
LYING ABOUT THIS.
PARTISAN LYING.
WHY THE COURT GRANTED THE
GOVERNMENT THE RIGHT TO SPY
ON THIS AMERICAN CITIZEN.
WOULDN'T IT JUST DISPEL ALL
THE MYTHS AND THE
CONSPIRACIES IF WE COULD SEE
REDACTED, OF COURSE, BUT IF
WEEKEND SEE THE BASIS FOR
IT?
>> WELL, WE HAVE NEVER
PRODUCED PUBLICLY THE FISA
WARRANTS.
BUT I HAVE TO TELL YOU,
TUCKER, WE HAVE PRODUCED
MORE DOCUMENTS IN THIS CASE
MORE INFORMATION TO THE
CONGRESS AND TO THE PUBLIC
THAN I THINK ANY ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE IN HISTORY
HAS.
WE ARE GOING TO GO AS FAR AS
WE CAN GO TO MAKE THINGS
PUBLIC AND WE ARE GOING TO
ENSURE.
>> Tucker: YOU DON'T THINK
WE NEED A SPECIAL PROSECUTOR
TO LOOK INTO THIS.
>> WE'RE GOING TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT.
IT COULD BE ONE DAY THAT A
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR WOULD BE
REQUIRED BUT WE ARE GOING TO
LOOK AT THIS BOTH WITH
ATTORNEYS AND WITHIN THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S OFFICE.
AND THEY WILL GET TO THE
BOTTOM.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE GIVING A
SPEECH TOMORROW
CIRCUMSTANTIAL ABOUT THE
RULE OF LAW, I THINK.
I READ A COPY OF IT TO THE
FEDERALIST SOCIETY.
IT RAISED A QUESTION IN MY
MIND ABOUT JUDGES.
SHOULDN'T THE CONGRESS ACT
AS A COUNTER BALANCE AGAINST
JUDICIAL OVERREACH?
IF THERE IS A JUDGE WHO IS
CLEARLY NOT CONSULTING THE
CONSULTATION AND MAKING LAW,
WHY WOULDN'T THE CONGRESS
TRY TO BALANCE THAT OUT.
>> IT'S GOTTEN TO THE POINT
WHERE CONGRESS, I THINK, HAS
BEEN TOO WILLING TO CREED RECEIE
BEEN TOO WILLING TO CREED RECEID
ITS POWERS.
I FELT THAT WHEN I WAS A
MEMBER OF THE CONGRESS, I
FEEL IT EVEN MORE SO NOW AS
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
WHEN I AM FINDING SINGLE
JUDGES ONE OUT OF 600 ISSUE
AN EXECUTIVE ORDER, AN
INJUNCTION, A COURT
INJUNCTION AGAINST EXECUTIVE
ORDERS OF THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH OF THE UNITED STATES
WITHOUT A FOUNDATION FOR
THAT.
YOU CAN HAVE 10 OTHER JUDGES
WHO OPPOSE IT BUT THE ONE
WHO ENJOINS IT, THEIR
OPINION IS UPHELD.
IT MAY TAKE 18 MONTHS TO GET
THE TO THE SUPREME COURT.
IT IS DISRUPTING THE ABILITY
OF THIS GOVERNMENT TO
FUNCTION.
AND I'M REALLY CONCERNED
ABOUT IT.
IT'S TIME FOR THE NATION TO
RECONSIDER THESE
INJUNCTIONS.